[Applaudissements]
encore ça boit ça fait pas rire et je
vois cette huile est il honnête bojan il
le dit moi je pense qu'il ya plus de
gens comme ça de ce qu'on pense oui là
tous des gens que on n'a jamais eu une
histoire exact que ce qu'on pense que
c'est comme ça
oui merci et remplacé rafael nadal lé
marois bas kate a commenté roy pas vous
la démonter le show pig si fameux tout
appareil ou tout non mais oui c'est tout
excessif mais mes parents il est quand
même chaud faut faire gaffe avec lui en
amont la ville en ville et il est quand
même chose d'origine espagnole quoi
cette d'origine espagnole oui c'est ça
prend c'est bizarre mais je parle
espagnol
j'aime bien parce que le gars en clair
un accent espagnol est situé par
l'espagnol